it's hard to believe that Adam Sandler
was once one of the most successful
comedy actors in Hollywood but since his
glory days Sandler has tumbled pretty
hard in flop after flop his career
appears beyond repair what's really
behind Sandler stagnant trajectory
costly and crappy the infamous Sony
hacks from 2014 revealed that Sandler
was regarded by many studio executives
as a waste of money
one Sony employee wrote we continue to
be saddled with mundane formulaic Adam
Sandler films another exec said that
Sandler's excessive private jet usage
when the studio's dime was stressing him
out he went on to detailed trips of
Sandler's costing in excess of sixty
eight thousand dollars of flight perhaps
suggested the executive Netflix with
whom Salman has recently partnered could
share the cost of the failing stars
offices on a lot which were in the
studio two million a year then again
maybe not
Netflix's regrets Sandler's first
release of his for picture deal with
netflix the ridiculous six garnered
publicity in all the wrong ways during
filming a dozen Native American actors
walked off set after hearing what they
felt were racist jokes but when it was
finally released the movie actually set
a record as the most watched film on
Netflix within its first 30 days then
again the film was harshly criticized
for what many saw as its racist concepts
and undertones the ridiculous six
managed to score ridiculous zero percent
on Rotten Tomatoes print is dead to him
Sandler himself doesn't seem interested
in challenging his unfavorable media
portrayal after press junkets for Billy
Madison he apparently read some
unfavorable descriptions of himself and
decided to stop talking to print
journalists altogether an arrangement no
one really seems to mind these days
Sandler's Twitter feed perhaps his best
means of reaching fans is hardly
engaging no ladies man Sandler has also
earned bad marks for his portrayals and
relationships with women in Hollywood in
June of 2016
actress Rose McGowan tweeted out a
casting notice she received from one of
Sandler's movies that encouraged women
auditioning to wear quote form-fitting
tanks that show off cleavage
push-up bras encouraged unquote soon
after calling out Sandler on Twitter
McGowan said she was fired by her agent
and a social media outcry
did meanwhile at a premiere for Hotel
Transylvania 2 he and co-star Kevin
James both and what appeared to be gym
clothes were photographed next to a very
dressed up Selena Gomez the images
sparked a debate online about double
standards for men and women in Hollywood
and seriously come on guys you don't own
shirts with buttons Sandler may have
played a girl in Jack & Jill but he
doesn't seem to relate well with them
stale co-stars comedy posses are no new
phenomena especially among SNL alumni
but Sandler's insistence on working time
and again with actors like David Spade
Kevin James and Rob Schneider may be
preventing him from reaching younger
fans he did hire Natasha Leggero for his
Netflix release that do-over
but relegated her to a supporting crazy
wife role leaving the more substantial
acting to David Spade in the case of the
do-over this resulted in another slew of
disastrous reviews but hey Lisa turned
higher praise than his previous outing
when the ridiculous 6 has a mind
bottling 0% of Rotten Tomatoes the
do-over blows it out of the water with a
5% I award you know points and may God
have mercy on your soul thanks for
watching
subscribe to our YouTube channel to
watch more videos at the one you just
saw and leave us a comment to let us
know why you think Adam Sandler's career
isn't what it used to be